oh what a first day of the impeachment
trial
it was we seen a lot of stuff
a lot of [ __ ] all the way up to your
waist
on the second half the democrats
destroyed the [ __ ] [ __ ] arguments
that trump had
trump's lawyers had in his brief if you
want to call them [ __ ] lawyers if you
watch the second half
of this goddamn thing if you want to
call them attorneys at
all jesus [ __ ] christ number one
the democrats destroyed this
constitutional argument
absolutely destroyed it on its face
now not only did they get all [ __ ] 50
democrats to vote
that this thing is constitutional they
got six
six republicans six
romney murkowski collins
cassidy toomey
and there's one other i can't think of
them there's six of them
now i don't believe that these
republicans are going to vote to convict
donald trump we're not going to get 67
votes to convict here but that
doesn't [ __ ] matter here's why it
doesn't matter
it's because at this point really is it
is it about convicting donald trump
or is it about this country and doing
what's
right doing what is [ __ ] decent here
and the decent thing to do is follow the
constitution
and try this [ __ ] fat slob
we impeached him while he was the
president
he was the president when he did this
[ __ ] thing
the insurrection he was the president
when they impeached him for doing that
[ __ ] thing
and citing the insurrection so he should
be tried
in the senate like any other [ __ ]
impeachment would be
and all 50 democrats including six
republicans agree with that
and the reason why they do is because
the democrats
the house democrats management team made
a decent [ __ ] argument for the
constitution
this is a really weird [ __ ] argument
that this thing is not constitutional
and the reason what the first reason why
it's [ __ ] weird is the obvious one
well he did the thing that you accuse
him of doing
but you can't try him because it ain't
constitutional
it's like a [ __ ] loophole that they
want to have
like in a murder trial like some kind of
[ __ ] murder trial
lupo here yeah he killed him but by god
he killed him on the eighth day
and that that that just doesn't go well
me a [ __ ] break of course it's
constitutional nowhere in the
constitution does it say
you cannot try someone because they're
not in public office it does not say
that anywhere
in the constitution nowhere
they're making dumb [ __ ] arguments
because they have they don't have
[ __ ] [ __ ] that works in their favor
here
everything works against donald trump in
this manner
and the video the video of the timeline
and the insurrection
every american should be required to
watch that [ __ ]
the entire video front to back
and make a decision whether this guy's a
piece of [ __ ] or not
who cares about the trial this guy's a
low-life piece of [ __ ]
scum has been his whole [ __ ] criminal
life
and he will continue to be rather the
senate convicts him or not
and that's the point here is how history
will judge donald trump
and more importantly how history is
going to judge the vote of these
republicans
because we can hold them to account we
as the voters
can hold these republicans to account
and hold donald trump to account jesus
if they don't get a conviction
and he can run in 2024 guess who can
vote against that [ __ ] this next
time
all 81 million of us plus plus probably
another 10 million of republicans
who have left the republican party
because they have taken up the mantle of
this [ __ ] bag
and they can't stand to be part of this
party who would want to be
who would [ __ ] want to be and i
really think today is a line in the sand
because bruce castor got up and started
swooning pack to me because they knew
they might lose pat toomey's vote
and the reason why they're going to lose
pat toomey's vote here is because they
went on and on and on about how the
state of pennsylvania the vote was fraud
the whole system was fraud
well pat toomey has to run in that state
again
he can't run around the state of
pennsylvania telling people oh well that
election was fraud but the one i'm in
that one's okay doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense
so of course pat toomey is gonna vote to
remove this [ __ ]
remove him convict him
oh how sweet it would have been if they
would have moved on this trial as fast
as they moved on supreme court justices
then maybe we wouldn't have this stupid
boneheaded argument about if it's
constitutional
or not the [ __ ] out of here
a drunk driver hits and kills a family
of five
[Music]
gets indicted for murder but then he
happens to lose his job in the meantime
well we can't convict him we can't take
him to trial
that drunk driver lost his job
we can't do that how the hell are we
going to convict this guy
he lost his job we can't take him to
trial and and
and try to see if if we can get a
conviction a
murder a murdering five
people in a car because he was drunk
driving we can't do that
[ __ ] we can't [ __ ] around and find out
hide and watch
we will tomorrow they're gonna start the
real [ __ ] arguments
and the stark difference between trump's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] ass legal team jesus christ where
did they find these [ __ ] ambulance
chasers at
the first guy bruce castor he you didn't
even know what the hell he was saying
couldn't find his spot in his notes he
had no clue what the [ __ ] he was talking
about
just rambled on and on and on he'd have
better he'd been better off getting up
and saying
yep trump did it and what the [ __ ] he
gonna do about it
he'd have been better off and the second
guy
david shone
that angry [ __ ] reminds me of
myself
gets so pissed off
and some people are asking about him
drinking water he is holding his head
when he was drinking water
and they're saying it's a religious
thing i don't know if that's true or not
i don't know anything about his religion
i do know one thing though he's a [ __ ]
for brains and it looked like he was
trying to hold his [ __ ] for brains in
rudy giuliani's [ __ ] for brains comes
from the side maybe this guy's comes
from the top
because he doesn't seem very [ __ ]
religious to me he didn't have much
religion
if he's defending donald [ __ ] trump
so we'll see tomorrow how this turns out
but i'm sure
i'm sure that there's going to be at
least
one maybe two more republicans that are
gonna walk over to the other side i just
remember the other republican
ben sasse can you imagine can you
imagine if trump still had a twitter
account
he would have been on the [ __ ] the
whole time the whole time tweeting mean
tweeting as they were voting against him
well [ __ ] donald trump and anyone who
looks like donald trump
[ __ ] him